kyle is with us in New York hi Kyle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
hey doing better than I deserve what's
up hey so I'm a real estate guy got my
license shortly after you did I was 22
when I got my real estate license and
I've been in the business about 14 years
happy on the investment side I'm at
portfolio rental portfolio that's about
3.5 million dollar net worth about a 68%
equity position in it and I did a
calculation I'm sort of relatively new
fan and I appreciate all the stuff
you're putting out there and so I did a
calculation to figure out what it would
actually take if I used all of the cash
flow to point right at the debt how long
it would take to actually pay all of it
off which I came out to about ten years
and three months but I guess my question
is value in doing that versus value on
continuing to use the cash flow to grow
the portfolio which to date is basically
what I've been doing yeah okay so you've
got a top-line asset base of three and a
half million not net worth correct yeah
total portfolio value is three and eight
point five five equity is one point one
three two so what you got 14 15
properties right about there yep yeah
okay cool good for you
well done very well done and you're in
the 70% equity position meaning you only
have 30% of in debt so less than a
million dollars in debt no reversion oh
so 68 percent leverage oh okay so you
don't have a ton of cash flow
it's about monthly after all expenses
mortgages you know capex everything is
around seventy seven hundred a month
yeah yeah that's not much okay that's
what I thought I thought it was tight
I mean seventy seven hundred months a
lot of money but not on three and a half
million it's not so that's that's you
know
okay here's the thing you said you're
new to all this here's what I went
through we had about four million
dollars for the real estate and owed
about three on it so we're in about a
seventy five percent ratio but some of
that a percentage of that probably only
me and that was on 90-day notes because
we were doing flips okay this is back in
the 80s way back okay and I was in my
20s I had grown that from nothing in
just a few years and so I leveraged into
every bit of it obviously but I did good
buys like you have done which gave me
strong equity positions and so you know
I was at about about the same l2v you're
sitting at roughly in a little higher
but but I had a heart risk position
because of the 90-day notes and the
flips which is actually what took me out
that's what broke me because the bank's
called the notes on the 90-day notes
bank got sold and they freaked the new
bank freaked out when they looked over
and saw a kid in his 20s that owed a
million dollars and so they new guy
freaked out and that started that tumble
that I couldn't recover from and so what
I learned from that process was a lot of
things of course but as a real estate
guy one real estate guy - another real
estate guy I learned that let me stop a
second okay in I also got a finance
degree and in the process of getting the
finance degree we were taught in other
investments to not measure risk
investments with lower high risk
investments with low risk investments
apples to apples meaning an example
would be an aggressive growth stock
mutual fund which is much more volatile
than a growth and income mutual fund
okay
you wouldn't compare it making a 20%
rate of return
with a growth in income making a 10%
rate of return apples to apples and say
oh we're going to discount we're not
going to consider risk we're just going
to go with the 20% the higher rate of
return because we
you consider risk you equalize out those
two funds the lower risk and the high
risk you have to mathematically put the
risk in and in that world there's a way
to mathematically insert risk it's
called a beta and it's a statistical
measure of risk the volatility of the
hills and valleys if you chart it and
all of that okay so all of that to say
is there's actually a math formula that
you can use when comparing two
investments of that type because the
beta is stated by the mutual fund
company it's a volatility index and long
story short you can adjust for risk so
you can compare a high risk investment
with a low risk investment
apples-to-apples does that make sense
okay now having said that then when I
went broke in real estate business I
suddenly realized that in the real
estate business which I grew up in we
are not taught risk at all we're just
taught it's all leverage and it's all
good all the time but common sense tells
you the more leverage you have the
higher leverage you are meaning if you
had a 90% leverage position instead of a
70 68 percent leverage position you
would be at a higher risk agreed right
but we don't adjust for that correct and
if you had a a 100% paid for real estate
portfolio your risk would have
dissipated like light-years from where
you are today agreed
yep and yet we're not taught to
mathematically adjust for that all we're
taught to do is go let's take the cash
flow buy more real estate let's go in
debt some more we do not adjust for the
risk of leverage in the world that you
and I are in okay we're not taught that
nobody does and so we that leads us to a
faulty presumption that risk isn't there
and so we just go buy stuff on that just
let's just that you would always take I
mean what kind of fool wouldn't have
debt on real estate and we just go buy
real estate and that's what I did four
years and what I believed for years
because I was not taught academically
and no one in academics that I've ever
found I've never
anyone who actually applies a risk
formula to the leverage issue in real
estate but it's there we know it's there
from common sense all of that babbling
to say I came to the conclusion and I've
actually run some pretty sophisticated
math models I developed myself because
I'm a math nerd that shows that paid for
real estate will prosper you a smaller
portfolio of paid for real estate will
prosper you more than a large portfolio
of leveraged real estate over the span
of 20 years okay and so high leverage
guys nothing down guys all those guys
that gone broke I knew a bunch of those
guys back in the day I don't know any of
them made it 10 years they all crashed
within 10 years like the like super high
leverage you're not that guy okay
but the nut you know the nothing down
crowd you know what I'm talking about it
right yeah well I mean in in all
fairness and disclosure I mean I I
started it with you know 17 grand
probably and we've you know kind of just
rolled up pulled the equity out
excellent fit up some of the money
wisely but you know it's all going right
back into the same exactly the same and
and you know if you look at 7700 flow on
what you got it's not that great right
you don't have that much movement for
the amount of money you are controlling
and manipulating every day yeah I mean
Kassala mean I think how you got there
I'm not gonna be mad about I'm just glad
you're there congratulations you've done
great if I'm you I'm gonna dial down
that risk for my long-term stability
I would rather own less real estate that
is working towards getting it paid for
so I might cherry-pick the portfolio and
keep the ones I really want to hold 20
years and some of these others that I'm
not that thrilled about I might flip the
equity out of those towards we're debt
reduction I might go the other way
matter of fact I know I would all of my
real estates paid for and I pay cash for
all of it and I got a bunch of it hey
man thanks for the discussion